I feel like you're the the king of
quarantine new releases just put me out
product it's a good thing a lot of the
stuff you're putting out right now is
feel-good family stuff which I think we
could all use a little of right now
certainly you know it's nice to be part
of something that hopefully is bringing
joy to people in these times are rough
so yeah this is a franchise that's been
bringing joy to people for a long time
now and I know you are a scooby-doo fan
so is there any specific quality of
shaggy that you came to appreciate even
more after playing the character you
know I think really his sweetness you
know and the stuff that I have over the
years as I get older that I appreciate
more and more is the heart of a
character it's so you know coming up I
started as a comedy writer and initially
last thing in the world does he want
anybody says oh you got to put some
heart into it I would just hate hearing
that it's like no just make everything
funny funny funny and yeah the older I
get the more I realize it's it's as
funny as a movie is if it doesn't have
that element of heart and connectivity
and groundedness people are only gonna
like it so much so so that was something
that I felt like with Shaggy I really
got to see sweetness and appreciate that
in a way that I had as a younger person
yeah you definitely feel it in this and
you know we obviously just spoke about
the Willoughby's - you have so much
voice acting experience even with all of
these films and shows under your belt
now is there any particular part of the
voice acting process whether it's the
production or even a voice technique
that you still find really challenging -
now I've been lucky enough to have had
now a good amount of voiceover acting
jobs so I'm
be comfortable doing it but this was so
different because this is such a beloved
character you know it's what is it it's
50 years old it's you know this
franchise is 50 years old I loved this
character so much I've loved it since
you know since I was born there has
never been a world that I've been in
where Scooby hasn't existed at love do
we wanted to do the interview by himself
but I think so but that was that made it
very tricky because it it it was so
stressful to come in a lot of times
you're going in doing characters that
just don't exist so you can do whatever
voice you want to and and then you don't
feel you're just not stressed about it
but this is there's such a history with
this voice and and the different
wonderful actors who have done it Casey
Kasem obviously the original and iconic
voice of Matthew Lillard so amazing as
well so so it you know you you want to
do it justice because you know there are
so many people who love this character
so you know I I don't sound like them
when I'm doing it it's it's different
but I I hope that people will be okay
with it the casey kasem easter egg was
easily one of my favorite things in the
entire movie also amazing so in honor of
Shaggy and Scooby and their eating
habits I wanted to ask you what is the
most outrageous or ridiculous thing that
you make yourself to eat back in college
we would do these challenges which were
we were trying to it was we would try to
see who could eat the grossest stuff
possible so you would be mixing
salsa the hottest hot sauces dog food at
times the grossest collection of things
I think one time somebody put chewing
tobacco in it was just something that no
human being should ever eat and that's
that's gonna take the cake but it was it
was not it was just a bunch of you know
college kids doing it so as an adult I
feel like I just eat a lot more ice
cream that I should it doesn't it's not
crazy it's just it's it's more quantity
thing than a quality thing and I think
as I get older I just needed better with
my cholesterol thank you so much for
your time again and another
congratulations on the movie awesome
thank you good talking to you again